حزب الاراء وتكميم الافواه الى حجب من نوع
اخر اعلن عنه وزير الداخليه الايرانيه
احمد وحيدي وهو حزب العالم الافتراضي من
ايران بشكل كامل وزير الداخليه الايرانيه
عزى السبب لمواجهه من وصفهم بالاعداء
الذين يعملون على صنع برامج لرفع الحجم
بالاضافه الى تشكيل لجنه للتحقيق في
الاضرابات الاخيره بالبلاد وتقديم
المتهمين للقضاء وكان النظام الايراني قد
نفذ اجراءات سابقه في حجب تلغرام ومواقع
التواصل بعد اندلاع التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه
ضد غلاء المعيشه وتدني الاجوره بالمناسبات
قبل شهرين تحدث الماسك عن تزويد المحتاجين
في ايران بالانترنت عبر تقنيه ستار لينك
واناقشه مع البيت الابيض امكانيه اطلاق
خدمات الاتصال بواسطه منظومه اقمار ستار